happy Halloween hey guys and ghouls i'm
abby sharp from Abby's kitchen but
tonight for $9.99 on ebay unsexy us now
Halloween means different things to
different people depending on where you
are in your life when you're six it
means putting a tiara on and stocking up
on candy that you're probably gonna
hoard for the next 12 months when you're
19 it means wearing as little clothing
as possible and getting passed out drunk
and when you're my age you just want to
get through the night without getting
yourself completely sick on candy corn
so I came up with a healthy menu to a
friend big or little supermen witches
sexy nurses and whatever the hell that
is
I even included a little drinky drink
for an adult trick and treat let's get
started
first up my pumpkin shaped grilled
cheese using these cute Halloween cookie
cutters I cut two slices of pumpernickel
bread into the shape of a pumpkin
next I melt two tablespoons of butter
and brush it onto the outsides of the
pair so you can use less butter next I
spread the inside of one slice of bread
with hot pepper jelly a few slices of
orange tomato and a little cheddar
cheese these older the cheese the better
so you can get away with using less top
it off with the other slice of bread
butter side up and transfer it to a pans
preheated to medium
cook for about two-and-a-half minutes
until golden brown and carefully flip it
over and cook it on the other side for
another two and a half minutes
next because every girl cheese needs a
big bowl of tomato soup I thought I'd
spooked by ours with my eyeball floaters
using a small paring knife cuts from all
stuff with pimentos in half next I cut a
little crater out of some [ __ ] shiny
balls it's a large enough diameter to 50
Olive in so you don't want to go down
further than halfway stuff the olive
half into the cheese ball and continue
with the remaining bocconcini balls to
serve ladle out of serving of your
favorite homemade or store-bought tomato
soup and drop a few eyeballs down into
it serve some grilled cheese for dunking
and finally we're brewing up my creepy
ginger cocktail named after the time I
went on a blind date with a redhead
would stop complimenting my neck anyways
this cocktail features all my favorite
flavors plus the probiotic benefits of
kombucha
I apologize 1/2 a cup of freeze dried
berries in a food processor until they
reach them powder like consistency I for
1/2 a cup of pomegranate molasses into a
dish and rim my glass with the sticky
stuff before setting it into the berry
powder next give 6 or so we've removed a
little bruising in a glass with some
lemon juice and top it off with an antic
vodka ginger flavor kombucha and ice so
there you have it a spooktacular grilled
cheese a bowl of eyeball tomato soup and
a creepy ginger cocktail to get those
skeletons shaking and those witches
cackling and while Halloween is all
about a little fright factor you don't
need to be scared of waking up from the
sugar shakes after a candy filled night
no tricks here folks just good
old-fashioned foodie fun thanks so much
for watching guys for more great holiday
ideas be sure to subscribe to my channel
next time Abbey's kitchen